zum ersten mal überhaupt ist es
fachleuten gelungen einen blick hinter
ein schwarzes loch zu werfen mit hilfe
von zwei weltraumteleskopen konnte so
eine der exotischsten vorhersagen der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
bestätigt werden und wie die forschenden
das herausbekommen haben das ist
ziemlich ausgeklügelt klicks umsatz im
future abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's
herzlich willkommen
röntgenstrahlung die direkt hinter einem
schwarzen loch freigesetzt wurde genau
die haben jetzt us astronomen und
astronomen gemessen und diese
verborgenen lichtstrahlen ermöglichen
der fachwelt das wovon sie lange
geträumt hatte einen direkten blick
hinter ein schwarzes loch denn das hatte
schon albert einstein 1 berechnet
schwarze löcher krümmen die raumzeit so
stark dass wir quasi um sie herum
schauen können müssten wir kennen das
aus inter stelle wo der nobelpreisträger
gibt zorn als wissenschaftlicher berater
genau das hat visuell umsetzen lassen
absolut spektakuläre bilder die neue
studie aus den usa sorgt für aufregung
denn sie offenbart spannende details
über die gigantischen schwerkraftmonster
was also steckt hinter den massereichen
objekten im all und wie gelang es den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern überhaupt das
unmögliche möglich zu machen und die
röntgenstrahlung rund um das schwarze
loch zu messen die spannenden antworten
auf diese fragen und noch viel mehr
jetzt bei klicksafe user vor zwei jahren
2009/10 die absolute sensation das erste
bild eines schwarzen lochs zu sehen das
zentrale schwarze loch in der galaxie
m87 und dass es nicht einfach irgendein
schwarzes loch denn es handelt sich um
eines der größten schwarzen löcher
überhaupt 6,5 milliarden sonnenmassen
schwer und der ereignishorizont mit
einem durchmesser von 39 milliarden
kilometern nur zur erinnerung das ist
die grenze hinter der alles auch nicht
ins schwarze loch fällt das schwarze
loch selbst stellt sich die astrophysik
als winzigen kleinen punkt vor in dem
alles vereint ist und bei der größe des
ereignisses horizont von m87 handelt es
sich um den 260 fachen abstand der erde
von sondern mit dieser sensationellen
premiere dem ersten bild eines schwarzen
lochs wurde uns auch die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie vor augen geführt
dazu ein kurzer fun fact am rande albert
einstand hatte die existenz von
schwarzen löchern in der theorie selbst
vorausgesagt doch er persönlich glaubte
nicht daran zu verrückt diese idee doch
klar ist schwarze löcher verkörpern die
wirkung der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie und damit gemeint
ist die krümmung von raum und zeit die
so genannte raumzeit krümmung können wir
hier auf der erde in form der
gravitation erleben wir werden durch
diese krümmung auf die erde gezogen und
wir können sie in form von
gravitationswellen messen die masse
sorgt dafür dass die raumzeit gekrümmt
wird der masse zieht licht an licht hat
eine feste geschwindigkeit und kann
somit nicht beschleunigt werden deswegen
wird der raum kleiner oder anders gesagt
zusammengedrückt und bei einem schwarzen
loch ist der effekt so stark dass alles
in das schwarze loch gezogen wird und
ihm nicht entfliehen kann bei dem ersten
foto eines schwarzen lochs von vor zwei
jahren erschien er selbst als dunkler
schatten denn jegliche art von strahlung
oder materie die den ereignishorizont
eines schwarzen lochs überschreitet wird
eben verschluckt heißt also im klartext
die gravitationskraft der schwarzen
löcher ist so enorm dass sie das raum
zeit gefüge durchbrechen wenn der
sogenannte ereignishorizont
überschritten wird dann gibt es kein
zurück mehr und das gilt sogar für das
licht da sie alles an licht verschlingen
bleiben schwarze löcher selbst
unsichtbar dennoch verraten sie sich und
zwar durch ihren einfluss auf das licht
in ihrer umgebung doch wie können wir
uns ein schwarzes loch vorstellen wenn
wir es seitlich anschauen auf die helle
akkretionsscheibe also dem äußeren rand
des souks um das schwarze loch herum
denn dieses licht entsteht ja jenseits
des ereignishorizont und kann uns also
erreichen auch einmal einstein hatte
sich damals genau diese frage gestellt
und die theorie aufgestellt dass es in
einem solchen fall zu einer starken
krümmung der raumzeit kommen muss
konkret müsste also das licht von der
rückseite des schwarzen lochs umgelenkt
werden und dann an der vorderseite
wieder sichtbar werden von der erde aus
müsste man dann die vorder und rückseite
des schwarzen lochs sehen und genau das
wird beispielsweise in dieser simulation
der nasa sicht zu sehen sind hier zwei
supermassereiche schwarze löcher die
einander eng umkreisen die verzerrung
der raumzeit sorgt dafür dass wir beide
schwarzen löcher gleichzeitig von unten
und von oben sehen dargestellt sind in
dieser simulation ein schwarzes loch mit
rund 200 millionen sonnenmassen das
andere ist etwa halb so schwer dass
größere ist orange dargestellt dass
kleinere blau dargestellt dessen licht
ist kurzwelliger und heißer die
allgemeine relativitätstheorie geht also
davon aus dass die raumzeit um schwarze
löcher so extrem verzerrt wird dass der
region direkt hinter den masse monstern
sichtbar sein können es handelt sich um
eine gravitative gebeugte strahlung die
einen längeren weg zurücklegt und
bedingt durch die schwerkraft zu hören
wellenlängen verschoben ist doch ein
direkter nachweis für diese these von
albert anstand und den bisherigen
simulationen stand bis jetzt aus doch
ein us forschungsteam will nun
tatsächlich einen ersten blick hinter
ein schwarzes loch geworfen haben doch
wie soll das möglich sein dazu sagt der
us astrophysiker denn wilkens der an der
aktuellen studie beteiligt war jedes
licht das in dieses schwarze loch
eindringt kommt nicht heraus daher
sollten wir nicht sehen können was sich
hinter dem schwarzen loch befindet doch
die premiere ist gelungen und zwar mit
hilfe der beiden röntgenteleskop in
uster und xmm newton die fachleute haben
also zum ersten mal überhaupt
röntgenstrahlung eingefangen die von der
rückseite eines schwarzen lochs stamm
konkret hat er das astronomie team das
supermassereiche schwarze loch in der
etwa 59 millionen lichtjahre entfernten
galaxie zwicky 1 ins visier genommen so
konnten die teleskope röntgenblitze
detektieren röntgen emissionen die in
der direkten umgebung des schwarzen
lochs entstanden waren diese strahlungs
ausbrüche entstehen wenn ein fallendes
platz war mit den starken magnetfeldern
wechsel wird sprich durch die starke
gravitation beeinflusst wird reflektiert
wurden diese dann an seine
akkretionsscheibe und somit entstand ein
leuchten und zwar mit leichter
verzögerung als das forschungsteam
genauer hinsah offenbarte sich die
überraschung der zweite röntgen ausbruch
schien wie ein echo des ersten ausbruchs
schwächer und verzögert und so kamen die
fachleute zu ihrer entdeckung die
analyse der röntgen flairs enthüllt
kurze blitze von photonen ihre merkmale
mit einer von der rückseite des
schwarzen lochs stammenden emission
übereinstimmen dies sind lichtteilchen
die von der abgewandten seite der
scheibe abprallen und vom starken
gravitationsfeld um das schwarze loch
herum gebogen und verstärkt werden heißt
also die strahlung der röntgen ausbrüche
auf der abgewandten seite wird von der
akkretionsscheibe reflektiert die
schwerkraft des schwarzen lochs sorgt
dafür dass die um den ereignishorizont
nach form gebogen wird das licht stammte
also tatsächlich aus der region hinter
dem schwarzen loch die starken
röntgenblitze die an der staub und gas
scheibe rund um das schwarze loch
reflektiert worden waren sind für das
forschungsteam der beweis für diese
annahme denn die eigenschaften der
reflektierten strahlung offenbar dass
sie von allen bereichen der
akkretionsscheibe ausgeht und zwar eben
auch von der region direkt hinter dem
schwarzen noch diese stark davita tief
gebeugte strahlung wird durch die
schwerkraft zu hören wellenlängen
verschoben das reflektierte röntgenlicht
kommt zudem zu unterschiedlichen zeiten
an und zeichnet sich außerdem durch
unterschiedliche farben aus konkret ging
es den fachleuten vor allem um die
genaue struktur der eisenbahnlinie der
röntgenblitze denn die lichtstrahlen vom
teil der scheibe direkt hinter dem
schwarzen noch zeichnen sich dadurch aus
dass die eisenbahnlinie plötzlich heller
wird und dabei mit der zeit immer
langweiliger kein anderer mechanismus
kann das nach ansicht der fachleute
besser erklären als der dass die
strahlung im extremen gravitationsfeld
gekrümmt wird eben ganz so wie es dem
vorhersagen der relativitätstheorie
entspricht das forschungsteam konnte
also das unmögliche möglich machen und
sehen was hinter dem schwarzen loch
steckt dazu der astrophysiker denn
wilkens werden der studie beteiligt war
der grund dass wir es doch können ist
dass das schwarze loch den raum verzerrt
nicht beugt und magnetfelder um sich
selbst verdreht und genau damit gelangen
den us fachleuten der erste direkte
nachweis für diese these von albert
einstein denn er hatte ja vor rund 100
jahren zwischen 1905 und 1916 die
annahme getroffen dass die extreme
schwerkraft von schwarzen löchern die
raumzeit so stark verzerrt dass selbst
dahinter liegende regionen sichtbar
werden würden das fazit des us
forschungsteams lautet dementsprechend
die neuen beobachtungen bestätigen eine
schlüssel vorhersagen der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie
dass man die um das schwarze loch
gelenkten foto von der rückseite
detektieren kann unmögliches schwarzes
loch entdeckt anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren das geht hier oder mit dem
abo button unter jedem video ist
kostenlos und macht schlau bis dann
bleibt dran